now you'll explore how to build and
deploy applications with Google Cloud's
is solution compute engine
with compute engine users can create and
run virtual machines in Google's
Innovative data centers and on its
Global fiber Network
there are no upfront Investments and
thousands of virtual CPUs can run on a
system that is designed to be fast and
offer consistent performance
each virtual machine contains the power
and functionality of a full-fledged
operating system
this means a virtual machine can be
configured much like a physical server
by specifying the amount of CPU power
and memory needed the amount and type of
storage needed in the operating system
you can run any Computing workload on
compute engine such as web server
hosting application hosting or
application backends
a virtual machine instance can be
created by using the Google Cloud
console which is a web-based tool to
manage Google Cloud projects and
resources or through the gcloud CLI
the instance can run Linux and Windows
Server images provided by Google or any
customized versions of these images
you can also build and run images of
other operating systems and flexibly
reconfigure virtual machines
you might also be curious about compute
engine's pricing and billing structure
for the use of virtual machines compute
engine bills by the second with a one
minute minimum and sustained use
discounts start to apply automatically
to Virtual machines the longer they run
so for each VM that runs for more than
25 of a month compute engine
automatically applies a discount for
every additional minute
compute engine also offers committed use
discounts
this means that for stable and
predictable workloads a specific amount
of vcpus in memory can be purchased for
up to a 57 discount off normal prices
and return for committing to a usage
term of one year or three years
and then there are preemptable VMS let's
say you have a workload that doesn't
require a human to sit and wait for it
to finish like a batch job analyzing a
large data set for example
you can save money in some cases up to
90 percent by choosing preemptable VMS
to run the job
a preemptable VM is different from an
ordinary VM in only one respect
compute engine has permission to
terminate a job if its resources are
needed elsewhere
while savings are possible with
preemptable VMS you'll need to ensure
that your job can be stopped and
restarted
use Google Cloud's online pricing
calculator that you learned about in the
previous module to see pricing estimates
and discounts based on the different
configuration options that are available